as you've noticed a lot of you have um
have struggled with this and don't feel
bad like when I was at YouTube I
remember looking at this and I was like
what is this this is like black magic
people come up with these numbers and
they just have no reason they're just
like yeah but it works like but why okay
now mathematicians whenever they noticed
a problem like this knowing that there
is an answer right surely we can use
something we can take advantage of some
knowledge that we have to make this
process a little more straightforward
okay so here's the process they came up
with just give me a little space for
subheading I'm not going to tell you
what the subheading is yet because I
believe in spoiler three lessons okay
I'm going to show you this new technique
okay we're gonna have to pedal back a
little bit remember by the way the
reason why I'm learning this technique
is for one of you two reasons the first
reason you already know but this pairing
business is thinking of a pair of
numbers it can be quite hard
it's basically trial and error which is
not particularly efficient okay but
secondly there are some problems where
you literally cannot think of a pair of
numbers but it's impossible because the
numbers that you're going to end up with
either are whole numbers they're not
fractions they're just weird strange
numbers I'll show you one in a second
here's an example for question you can
write this down underneath your empty
sub here this is a very very simple
question okay you think it's not even
one of these on one of these messy ones
with a number out the front here it's
just it's morning okay how hard can it
be the answer is well pretty hard
because what do I want to do I would
usually think of a pair of numbers that
adds up to six and a pair of numbers
that multiplies two now you just have a
look at that for a second how many
numbers do you know that multiply to
seven all right so one is seven those
are the only ones right because seven is
a prime number right so those are the
early factors it has but one in seven at
least lost I checked one instead of do
go ahead up to six okay and you don't
have any other
options you can think of fractions if
you like they won't help so what am I
gonna do in this okay this question
defies this method which is why we learn
new ones
now when we have a look at this question
that I've just crafted out of thin air
the reason this one out is because it's
very similar to one you solved about ten
minutes ago you have a look on the board
right this question is almost identical
to this question do you see that and
this one was one of the easier ones to
solve right it wasn't hard okay so can I
take what I know about this question and
bring it over to this question right
let's just remember in case you've
forgotten the right here how do we solve
this guy x squared plus 6x plus 9 you
fold a pair of numbers and it's like
there's three and three it was the same
number twice okay
so therefore what she noticed when I
wrote this out in factorize four it was
a bit different to the others I would
write this so I actually want you to go
back to where you wrote this question
like go back a few lines and I want you
to put a big red box around this guy
this thing here write x squared plus 6x
plus 9 it's important when you factorize
it you end up with something where so we
call this a perfect square I know it
doesn't look like a perfect square like
the numbers we usually associate with
squares like 25 and 64 100 its head
trough you're like oh I know what those
are those are squares well this is a
square just the same it's just it has
algebra stuck in there so I want to
recognize these perfect squares and use
them to my advantage
here's how I'm gonna do it see this
question which was a bit prickly which
we didn't know what to do with it okay I
can turn this question into that
question and once I've turned it into
that question it's really easy okay
watch here's what I'm going to do for
starters the the difference between this
question and that question is this seven
you see the seven is not the number I
want it to be okay so I'm just going to
get the seven out of the way
okay I'm gonna put him on the right-hand
side so he's tucked out of the way and
what I have left over here is like part
of this question
it's like two-thirds of this question
right I'm just missing a little bit so
how do I turn this question into that
one the difference between them is a
plus nine do you see that so I'm going
to add nine to this side I've just made
that question into that question but
it's in the equation right you can't
just go randomly adding numbers because
you feel like it right if I add it to
the left I should also add it through
the right
are you following with me so far so I
added nine through the left and now I've
added it to the right okay now hold on a
second by doing this I have turned this
into a square right and you already know
how it factorizes it turns into this
right like maybe Tommy that 15 minutes
ago okay what do we get on the
right-hand side it's just numbers right
it's just two okay now this is we're not
there yet because I don't have a zero on
the right-hand side like I do for this
one okay so I'm going to do a little bit
extra but it's no hard right
I've got this squared how do I get rid
of a swear you take the square root
right so if I take the square root on
the left hand side I will take the
square root of the right hand side but
watch out I'm missing something
this example if I give you a simpler
question like say this x squared equals
25 take the square root of left left and
that gives me X when you take the square
root of the right that's five right but
it's not the only solution yeah because
it's a cord fried egg just like all
quadratics all of these guys they all
end up with two solutions don't they
okay and I'm expecting to hear maybe you
find you can square it you still get 25
so I've got the same dealing here with
this square root of two right Plus Ones
so far so good
all right I only need to do one will
think to get X by itself to get the
solution
get rid of +3 I'm gonna take away 3 from
both sides that leaves me with this okay
huh
now in a sense I'm finished this is the
solution like you know how we got here
there's two answers and here there's two
mantis
here are my two answers I've just sort
of bought them up into one lion let me
just write out the answers for you and
you should do the same
that plus or minus in then it really
means there's two numbers right
there's the minus one there's one
solution or there's the plus plan now
you can see why this kind of problem
despite how similar this looks to one
that you solved very easily before look
at what we ended up with at the end okay
these are the numbers that are going to
do this and you can't just think oh yeah
I'll try root 2 or root 3 or you're
never going to guess those ok let's just
quickly see by the way if I take these
two numbers minus 3 minus root 2 minus 3
plus okay I should be expecting when I
multiply them together I'm sort of
predicting what I should get let's just
quickly check out when you expand this
guy I don't looks a bit messy but minus
3 times minus 3 9 the negatives cancel
minus 3 times root 2 minus 3 root 2
watch out first set I've done the first
one now in the second one 2 minus root 2
times minus 3 the two negatives cancel
plus 3 root 2 minus root 2 times
positive root 2 that's just to back or
minus 2
these guys just cancel 9 minus 2 is 7
just like you predicted right so this is
a bit weird
these notes out here but this method is
what we used to get there's no
I did oh you mean put the -3 over here I
can't I enjoy preparations minus three I
could put over here it would still be
the same top bar minus three minus root
2 is the same as minus root 2 minus 3
that'd be fine it's just that it's a bit
weird to put that out the front I prefer
to put it in the middle that's true but
you're going to get a negative at the
front either way
you might have this thing unique or you
have that negative so it doesn't matter
which one now this one last 8 remember I
asked you to leave me an empty
subheading ok the crucial line was this
one that I highlighted in red where I
turned something that was not a square
into something that is a square all
right
see I was like missing a piece and then
we added to do so that's why this method
and some of you have met it before is
called completing this with what you
have on the left hand side isn't a
square but we rearrange it and twist and
turn it so that it is OK
so therefore this new technique we can
use it for anything
in fact I'm gonna ask you to try a Z it
just like we did for here I'd like to
use it on this question here you already
know what the answers are
ok so that's not what I'm worried about
I want to see if you can use this
technique on a question that we don't
need it for but it will help us for in
the future when we have questions that
you have any other choice but to do it
this way ok so right at this question
again fresh as if you haven't done it
before you do know what answers you're
expecting because we've solved this
already but walk through these steps I
live in there right you've got something
over here that's not a perfect square so
you get rid of that number and then you
complete the square right